Justin Jarrett
I was a cherry grower in Young in the ‘80s and decided to move to Orange for
all sorts of reasons.
One of those was for love.
Being a vineyard operator is very seasonal. So we have winter, where we prune
and get the vines ready for the next season.
Then they come into bud burst.
You've got to nurture that crop, protect it from disease.
Then by summer you're looking at, you've got the vines up and the fruit sitting
there, and then you come to the best time of the year, which is autumn and harvest.
And then you reap what you get and you put it all away, and then you have a rest for
about a week, and then you start all over again.
For Orange itself,
the effect of climate change is that what we did 20 years ago can't work today.
So you have to adjust, and it's not just the wine industry.
The apple industry is also having to do the same thing.
The cherries are having to do the same thing.
So agriculture itself is having to move and change because of the temperature.